Now, here in this room
what we wanted to do was give you an idea
of how to execute a Mid-century Modern,
and I'm gonna go with home office because it's 2021.
I actually started with the chair.
That was my inspiration.
Work from the chair.
I love this pop of color.
This red chair is from overstock.com and I love the shape.
And let's get honest for a second about a desk chair.
It must be comfortable.
But this is really great on your arms, as well as a back.
You can sit in it honestly for hours like we're stuck doing.
And then don't forget to get up
out of it and stretch every once in a while.
So for me, this was my beginning focal point.
And then I built around from there.
I love this lamp.
I found it at Home Depot.
This art I think is really true of a mid-century style
which is to break up a single piece of art
into two pieces and separate it.
It's very innovative.
It's got this cool edgy black
sort of painterly, swatches
and swipes in the middle, connecting it.
And I found those at Crate and Barrel.
Speaking of Crate and Barrel, I also found this globe.
I am a big globe collector.
I actually probably have about 50 globes at my house.
There's some things that not only I love decoratively,
but in this modern age, I love to tell my children
when we used to travel, where we're going on the globe.
It's educational and it's soulful.
Now this rug, I love it's from Ikea
and the circular pattern in it to me hearkens back,
definitely to mid-century.
So a lot of ways that you can execute
a very pointed design style
is available on modern websites everywhere.
It's just about having references,
building a mood board,
and then building it thoughtfully piece by piece.
Maybe don't go to one vendor for everything,
that also is really helpful in design,
no matter what you're doing.
When it comes to design, you want to remember the journey
of how and where you found that.
And that will, as Marie Kondo says, "Spark joy."
And VFFs we wanted to help you add
some mid-century style to your homes.
So each of you are getting
a $100 gift card from Costa Farms.
(audience cheers)
So that you can go buy a plant like we have here.
Because there's one thing I will say
about bringing the outside in,
I don't care what decade, our time period you're in
that is really timeless to have nature in your space.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪